foreign
[Music]
because the person was staying still and
then you'd push them backwards that's
not eating enough the person has to go
forward
they have to go forward okay they can't
just stay still and then uh we had times
where I was too far away and couldn't do
anything okay so we'll go back
and we also had times where you're
sitting here waiting do you see that
okay so already when the person comes in
let's look at this philosophically
clearly time manifests and space
manifests right and clearly there's a u
and there's a me okay that is precisely
why you're moving and I'm staying still
we start manifesting oppositions the
whole time so I'm waiting you're not
waiting I'm saying still you're not
staying still do you see that you're
coming at me I'm not coming at you you
see it just it's the way the universe
works okay as opposed to we go and you
see like I'm already moving
you see and if you pay attention at the
start I have already changed my
energetic values changed my mind values
and I will already be
ready that upon contact
we're going to adhere do you understand
that okay so we're going and we're
already adhering right now look at the
range you see the my here I'm in
what Keyhole laws are recognizes which
we for Simplicity Judo at a distance
okay really what it is is uh fighting
with the assumption that she is she is
armed and I am armed okay so I don't
want to do this if I'm armed you see it
actually grab my weapons I'll have to
change my angler stuff like that but I'm
out here then I'm armed she is armed she
can't reach her weapons because I have
her hands do you see that if I go here
she can grab a weaponing her weapon you
see got it Dad I'm not stopping her arms
so we're here like this same thing uh do
you feel that okay so you might want to
go back do you see go back
you see that that's there's the adhesion
right but based upon what she does go
back
I am making this happen did you feel
that okay so when she wants to go back
that's going to help my projection so
I'm I can tell that energy can go this
way
so you I want you to feel it okay so
first I'll show you she cannot go back
okay
and as she does try to go back because
she'll want to because she's off balance
go that's what I use for the projection
that energy you see but it all happens
we go it all happens quickly
oh
[Music]
okay
try it again
[Music]
foreign
do any
single whatever beginning they want to
do I would recommend you don't do the
keyhon
you understand
because that's like in the video where
you do a bottle to the face it's just
Jordan ski okay got it so a note to
everybody here try not to do this thing
you you want to do like weird things
okay and you'll get a more insightful
um
uh experience here so for example
instead of going like that there maybe
you just go here
you see or maybe you go here or maybe
you go there to something that you're
not used to right okay so uh now back to
you okay so on a couple of them I think
it was your third one you're coming in
and you came here
do you see this so this is not
the right mind for I think you
eventually went to
um
right here if we open it up to spari
what do you want to do
good
they do a groin strike there right uh
Rhoden what would you like to do from
here
I shoot it only like yeah you're gonna
do a double leg just do it if you get it
so you're all open to that okay
um you'll see that a lot and you will
see that in the video
I think it's like the third or the
fourth technique that the Aikido
practitioner does the person came in and
they did Ed me and take on a hip very
common in contemporary ideas again why
because you're never going to punch me
in the face or need me in the groin when
I do
this step you're going to just be there
and I get to go like that do you think
do you guys understand
so it's never going to be easy me
it's ishido 10 con they're over back at
the hand of distance again
or
it's out
on the 18 I'm aware of not this
I'm moving moving
you see hey if you pay attention then
what I actually did was brought her
around it I'm not going eating me 10 con
you guys understand
so
because this will not happen this is
wrong why I'm too close
and then two in a real situation knee
strike double leg
Etc
but right
I'm not in
the way strategy
come in here I'll turn you
you see on the other one she turns to
get me
whatever do whatever good
do you think she's turning herself in a
circle
pay attention you see her running in a
do you think she's doing that do you
think if I left her alone she's running
a circle
do you think I'm forcing her pay
attention go
so what's making her run in a circle
she's trying to press on me and
girlfriend do you see
but when I feel the pressure I moved she
keeps pressing on me
watch me stop it go faster yes
she does
so I'm not doing anything
it's woo way
so no
no
okay
try again
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
are you coming
do whatever you want to do whatever you
want to do
okay got it here we go
you want to stand up stand up
foreign
[Music]
there you go
good
out of it
again
out of it and out of it good
get out of it
out of it
yes
okay out of it
good
out of it
okay
out of bed
out of it
out a bit
get out of it
okay
again
let's try that again Watch
yeah
launch
do you feel that dude again you can come
harder so you can feel it
good harder
okay
get out of it
good
go back up
get out of it
what do you feel as you're trying to get
out there I want you to feel me to go
okay
again
foreign
get out of it
sit out of it
okay why did you notice
is that louder I almost feel you
feel any crashable
come in
try to get out
all I feel are these
sort of Points contact that we've talked
about and the uh the adhesion
I don't know where they're from it's
just it's
there's no force on poor self okay
anyone else what did You observe
what do you think the point
was that was trying to be made
louder that hurts to get out of it she
was actually generating
which means I don't have to stop you
I shouldn't try to stop you
you were trying to stop your okay
your uke came in with something
let's just call it X
the only way X becomes wrong
is when you have a desired for tactic
if there's no desired forms half tactic
every single counter is just X
do you understand that it's Just Energy
you just work with it okay it's not a
bad energy or good energy
it's the same initial energy the only
reason
you try to shape acts into staying the
same or becoming something else is
because your egoic mind is functioning
and is functioning dichotomously
X is or X is awesome
but then they change to something do you
see okay you don't want
anytime you have X you have non-x
you don't want X even
okay is you don't want non-x
there's you're trying to lift her right
arm do you see that yes so that's
pushing okay so that means her right arm
is going down
do you understand okay so we're gonna
stop you're not going you're going to uh
correct yourself okay okay so she wants
to take your arm up
and let's see what you were trying to
manifest okay so she's gonna let you do
whatever
that you were trying to take her right
arm up
so I want to see you lift your right arm
my right arm yeah because you were
holding her up there so you lift it and
now do whatever you wanted to do yep go
whatever do you see cool cool do you see
that okay so you had that technique
picked
but she's leaning on that arm so that's
the wrong my
do you see that when your attachment to
the technique
right kind of made it not work all right
we'll make the last Point first because
it's the same point I'll make the last
point we'll put it on video so you can
see it so you had a shoulder grab here
and you had that head here okay and you
guys see me use this one a lot okay and
you're thinking I'm gonna try that one
Sensei does that one a lot I I don't do
it
and there's no a lot because I don't
have that egoic centrality
I I either she did it as a way of saying
it poetically or I let her do it to
herself okay so if she's here
I'm never gonna take this head and shove
it over here to the other side of my
Center Line
do you see that because that's going to
take muscle
this movement
what I do instead is
she wants to come towards me you don't
have to do anything but try to get me
and can you do that for me okay so she's
coming at me
you've seen
and as she comes at me
that's what I move over there
then she just Falls
[Music]
she's here like this
and she tries not to fall she what do
you want to do to not fall
good okay so she goes like that
watch again over here it's a little
tricky
put your arm on my back
well you came around to do a barrel head
okay
so that arm now
let go of this arm okay
that will to hug around me is what's
doing this as I move out of nowhere you
see
so I want you to feel that
hey where have you bent over
okay and she goes around and I use it
okay all right so with that in mind
I think you're here
and here
there's a lot of pressure here so that's
not where I go you see
where
does she want again
do you understand what do you want to do
she wants to push that arm down
okay so I use that she wants to push
that arm down
go back
go and she's coming forward
she wants to push the arm down
[Music]
it's the exact opposite she wants to
push the arm down and I'm not trying to
take her up
she's going to do something I don't
know oh
let's say she's not doing anything
okay I'm here she's not doing anything
boom that's where your stripes come in
okay this is where your stripes come in
boom so but in this drill every unit is
doing something she's trying to get out
of I'll show you what you're trying to
get out I feel it you feel that okay so
what is she feeling
um I'm gonna go ahead and do it she
feels that I have her Center
you see so she's gonna try to get out of
her Center while attacking
whoa there he is right there
okay
but if your mind goes dichotomous
all of this is out of all of it is
alkaline okay
let's try it again